today we're talking about game changing
automation with gke
bigquery bi engine and keeping the cloud
safe
i'm stephanie wong and welcome to this
week in cloud where we serve you the
lowest latency news
organizations that need the highest
levels of reliability
security and scalability for their
applications
choose google kubernetes engine or gke
until now kubernetes still involved a
fair bit of manual assembly and
tinkering
to optimize it for your needs we're
introducing
gke autopilot a revolutionary mode of
operations for managed kubernetes that
lets you focus on your software
while gke autopilot manages the
infrastructure like
auto scaling and auto upgrades of nodes
plus
day two operations we're also
extending bigquery bi engine to work
with any business intelligence
or custom dashboarding applications that
require
sub second query response times in this
preview
bi engine will work seamlessly with
looker and other popular bi tools
without requiring any change to the bi
tools themselves
not only is bi engine now natively
integrated into the bigquery api
you can also reserve bi engine capacity
in your own gcp
project check out the announcement for
more info
this podcast will bring you stories and
insights on security in the cloud
and what we're doing at google cloud to
help keep customer
data safe and workloads secure we'll do
our best to cut to the heart
of real security questions and issues if
you have topics you're interested in
hearing about
listen to the podcast and let us know
need a quick overview of google cloud
core technologies
quickly learn these 21 google cloud
products from anthos to pub sub
each explained in under two minutes
check out the blog to read more
and see the videos if you want to read
more about these announcements or see a
full list
check out the link any thoughts or ideas
leave us a comment or tweet us
we'll see you in the cloud
you